Quentin Tarantino and Miramax have  reached a settlement over the lawsuit  regarding Tarantino's attempt to make  nfts from the movie Pulp Fiction to  which Miramax owns a lot of the rights  if you don't recall Miramax claimed that  Tarantino was infringing miramax's  copyrights over the movie Pulp Fiction  when he planned to create nfts based on  certain portions of the script to the  movie itself it's a shame that we'll  probably never learn the actual outcome  of this suit there were arguments on  both sides Miramax owned the right to  the movie itself but Tarantino probably  had a good argument that he owned the  rights to his handwritten screenplays  where an nft falls on that Spectrum who  knows but it would be interesting to  have actual case law on that suit and  while we won't know who won or lost this  lawsuit we do know that there is a true  loser here it's the person that bought  Tarantino's first nft for 1.1 million  dollars